monsieur le ministre crise énergétique
difficulté d'approvisionnement et de
recrutement l'industrie est de plus en
plus affectée la situation des
trésorerie continue de se dégrader dans
tous les secteurs et très en deçà de la
moyenne de long terme conclusion du
rapport de la Banque de France sur la
conjoncture en octobre 2022 assez
difficultés se rajoutent le
remboursement du psg-e et des charges
sociales qui n'ont pas été réclamés
depuis 2021 forcément ces charges
exceptionnelles sont trop lourdes pour
les entreprises et les rendre
vulnérables à ce sujet ici en commission
des finances nous vous avions déjà
alerté sur la durée de remboursement des
PGE que l'ont jugé incompatible avec la
marge des entreprises alors vous allez
me répondre que les entreprises peuvent
revoir la durée du remboursement du PGE
à condition de passer par la médiation
du crédit oui mais médiation est une
entité adossée à la Banque de France
si la réponse est négative l'entreprise
devra rentrer dans une procédure
collective si elle est positive
l'emprunt sera apparenté à une
restructuration de la dette et donc
considérée comme des empreintes non
performants sur le bilan cela aura donc
un impact sur la cotation d'entreprise
et quel qu'en soit la taille bilan
l'entreprise ne pourra plus souscrire
aux emprunts bancaires pour innover
aussi développer vous comprenez alors
pourquoi cette option est si peu
utilisée et pourquoi bon nombre de chefs
d'entreprise réinjectent leur patrimoine
personnel au risque de tout perdre
l'entreprise France a une moyenne de 6
salariés toutes tailles confondues y
compris de quoi le CAC 40 vous avez
entrepris une démarche de
réindustrialisation de la France mais ne
laissons pas tomber si TPE et PME qui se
décourage face à cette situation
pensez-vous ré-étaler le PGE sans
médiation particulière et à surseoir
temporairement le remboursement des
cotisations sociales des années
antérieures